and if you if you've got this already
and you're like I'm fine with this maybe
you just want to watch how to make sure
you found you haven't gone too far in
this pepper induction is circular in a
sense because this is what we talked
about this being dangerous before right
we also starting where we want to end
right so you may feel like you're going
in a loop but you shouldn't do multiples
just just do the one and end up where
you started okay if you if your solution
is fine so if it's a bit computing I
want to prove that ain't you - and it's
always difficult I hated it's something
very kind of chewy I hope that one
produces like 21 yeah really
bodis things tend into 21 times 21 point
263 so let's keep going
Carol yeah I've never got my setup for
my proof so I'm going to take the left
hand side and I'm gonna go through there
okay what's that equal [ __ ] I'm you can
see already you just can't have to muck
around a little bit with your indices
right hand or your index law as well so
I've got 3 to the 4 K plus 4 so because
up here in the index I have some that's
gonna convert to a product right and I
might as well mention because they're
not really the same thing but in Reverse
right see how I went from a song to a
product right indices exponents
Exponential's and logarithms right there
are the inverses of each other
so that's why when you've got an index a
sum to be expanded to a product when
you've got a lot of it's exactly the
other way around right when you've got a
a product you can expand that into a
song okay
and it's you going - one okay now at
this point I look and I think I've sort
of expanded out it's not really where
much else to go here except for our
assumption that we just watch it okay so
how can I work massage my assumption so
that it can fit into this you may have
taken the 3 to the 4 and seen sorry the
3 / 4 K and oh just you've got that here
right you sure this 3 before that's in
the way right so you've got two
alternatives here okay you could change
this so that it has the three of the
four K minus one and then you can
substitute that for your ATP okay
alternatively and I've seen a few people
do this which is why our attention to it
now maybe you want to take the 3 to the
4 K and just substitute that if you want
it that's fine however I can't do it at
the moment because I don't have 3 to the
4 K or something right my assumptions a
little different so I'm gonna work
really love my assumption first provide
I've done this earlier right I can say 3
to the 4 K just looking at infinity all
the way around is ATP plus 1 I'm just
shifted and what that does if I make
that much statement that I assume I can
bring that in quite easily right what do
I have here
I've got ATP plus 1
and this I've got to make sure I say why
I made this substitution pizza by
assumption please please please you
might be sure caught up in and actually
getting to the answer you forget to say
this in place so make a special note
okay what do I get from here well the P
these are actually numbers I can do a
bit right so that 3 the 4 is a 81 right
so the ATP plus 1 times 81 and I can
expect you now I could say what's 81
times 80 ok
I'm not going to I'm just gonna leave
them as separate times you see why the
second so I'm gonna have to refactor
eyes remember where I'm trying to end up
okay I want 80 times something ok so if
I've got 80 times something amount of
lead in that step so I've got a e P
times 81 plus 81 minus 1 so ADP 80 okay
I'm almost there do you see Ezra
trickier because what you're trying to
prove is no peas in it okay but it's got
a huge is meant to be some other number
well what's the some other number I can
find it by taking out my factory baby
what I have in the brackets is 81 P plus
1 leg
alright now what you might like to do on
the site donating through this I don't
think either working but just sitting
you understand this coming up did I
think I would say as P is an integer
right
since P Z this job there for 81 times P
plus 1 right that thing is also an
integer right you take the whole number
you multiply by some other whole number
and you had another whole month but
everything's talking in on those okay so
you should still be in the same set
therefore I can make my next step which
is well that's equal to since it behaves
the rules that I've said for Q I can
just say well that's cute okay that's
the shoe I was looking for that's cute
where Q is equal to 81 and that's my
proof so all that's left now is my
explanation okay therefore by the
principle of mathematical induction the
statements true for so pretty neat right
so this is why I was starting to get
into this topic and how you can use it
to prove I mean where would you go
really apartment is a few dollars and it
works okay this is logical and it shows